Ah Skip, here we go again...
It’s time for us to take another crack at
putting SCP-682 six feet under, once and for
all.
If you’ve been following this channel for
any amount of time, then there’s one thing
you know for certain: SCP-682 is harder to
kill than pretty much, well, anything!
We’ve made multiple videos on the Foundation’s
failed attempts to finally terminate the beast,
and we made a video with some of your ideas
on how to finally slay the monster.
And considering you’re watching this video
right now, you can probably guess how that
went.
Now it’s time for one more run at the Death
Star: and once again it’s with your ideas
from comments and community post responses,
let’s see if any of them can help us finally
put this ill-tempered reptile to rest.
If we can’t…
well we’re not blaming you, but also it’s
your fault.
Let the community termination attempts commence!
Anais McBride suggested, “Ask the Witch
Child.”
SCP-239, also known as The Witch Child, is
one of the most dangerous and powerful anomalies
out there.
She’s a small girl with
unparalleled reality-warping
mental abilities, so powerful that her very
brainwaves alone can be passively fatal.
However, the problem is,
her power is so potentially
dangerous that she’s forever kept in a kind
of medically-induced anomalous coma.
Dr. Alto Clef thinks she’s so dangerous
he’s even campaigning to have her terminated.
As a result, the O5 Council has forbidden
any cross-testing between 682 and 239, fearing
the consequences of 239 gaining 682’s powers
and becoming a truly unstoppable threat capable
of causing an XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
Syed Zamin Ali Shah Kazmi Mushadi suggested,
“Kill him with SCP-734.”
This is an interesting one.
SCP-734, also known as The Baby, is an anomaly
that causes a painful degenerative disease
that eventually disintegrates the entire body
and kills the victim if they so much as come
into contact with the baby or its fluids.
However, based on cross-tests with other,
similar “touch it and die” anomalies like
SCP-409 - the Contagious Crystal - we can
probably guess how exactly this would go down.
In all likelihood, the Baby’s anomalous
effects would infect and destroy large portions
of SCP-682’s body.
However, at this point, 682 would adapt to
the threat, and begin to reverse it and heal.
Even worse, it’s likely that 682 would steal
the ability for a limited time, and become
deadly to the touch.
Caden Griffin suggested, “Why don't you
use the Dragon Slayer to terminate 682?
It has proved itself many times in fights
with LSAs.”
SCP-5514, the Dragon Slayer, is essentially
a giant fighting robot designed to take down
killer kaijus with its
plethora of state-of-the-art
anomalous weapons and defenses.
However, we’d still argue that while it
could definitely help in immobilizing 682
during a rampage, it doesn’t have much of
a chance of actually killing it.
Let’s look at SCP-001, the Gate Guardian,
a supernatural warrior with a blade hotter
than the sun, capable of cleaving atoms in
half.
Even he couldn’t kill SCP-682.
So a robotic approximation with only a fraction
of the Gate Guardian’s power is probably
not going to have any real chance of killing
682.
ImAChuckster48 suggested, “Make it bite
its tongue so hard that it just destroys itself.”
While we can certainly attest from personal
experience that this really, really hurts,
we worry that if ever 682 bit its own tongue
really hard, it’d just drive it into a state
of murderous rage.
Though we do take a small piece of satisfaction
in knowing its tongue would probably be in
distress for a few minutes afterwards, it’s
unlikely to wipe out the beast once and for
all.
Liezel Rolle suggested, “How about we just
put SCP-682 in 2317's cell.”
SCP-2317 is an old wooden door that functions
as a portal into the domain of a planet-destroying
monster known as The Devourer of Worlds, a
being that many believe is associated with
the Scarlet King, and will inevitably escape
and cause an XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
While you may be thinking, “Perhaps it’ll
kill 682”, it’s more likely that they’d
collaborate, seeing as they both want the
same thing.
Namely, to kill everyone.
If you let 682 in, chances are, it’ll come
back through that door with the Devourer right
on its tail - then, it’s all of our problems.
Guest123 116 suggested, “Drop him in Russia
so they can terminate him.”
The Foundation has technically already tried
this.
They dropped 682 into SCP-3930, a patch of
literal non-existence in Russia that causes
anything that goes inside of it to cease to
exist.
And afterwards?
He was fine!
So yeah, dropping him anywhere in Russia is
probably just going to get a bunch of innocent
Russian civilians killed.
Mysher said, “The Foundation shouldn't worry
about how to kill him, but how to stop his
ability to adapt.
I would suggest typing "Scp 682 no adaptability
juice" or something like that into SCP-294
and then kill him by any means, which SHOULD
kill him forever.”
An interesting theory, but what if he simply
adapts to SCP-682 no adaptability juice?
Then we’d really be in trouble...
MarioTGP said, “Give him a twitter account,
he'll be canceled instantly for his spicy
opinions.”
SCP-682 would cancel Twitter itself, for not
having opinions that are spicy enough.
Sorry, Jack.
SCP-096 - still sore about losing the battle,
we assume - said, “Let him fight the queen
of England.
After all, she’s immortal too.”
We definitely think it would be interesting
to see SCP-682 go head to head with the Queen
of England.
Based on all the knighting she does, we know
that she at least has a sword, though we don’t
know if that sword is as powerful as the one
wielded by the Gate Guardian.
But regardless of the outcome, the battle
would definitely change history.
Every history book would simply read: “SCP-682
Punched the Queen”, everything else would
just be a footnote.
Noah Cordero said, “Use SCP-2935 to kill
the lizard.
As you can see in the video, he will die.”
SCP-2935, also known as O’ Death, is probably
one of the scariest and deadliest SCPs out
there.
It killed an entire alternate dimension, including
an alternate SCP-682.
The problem is, putting our 682 into 2935’s
alternate reality could lead to the destruction
of our entire dimension.
Why’s that?
Because, if 682 was somehow able to return
to our world from the world of 2935, it could
bring the spirit of death itself back with
it and kill us all in the process.
Explorando con beto 1 suggested, “SCP 682
vs Lady Dimitrescu.”
While Resident Evil 8’s Lady Dimitrescu
has certainly captured all of our hearts,
we don’t think she’ll be bringing home
the W on this one.
Lady Dimitrescu has a powerful adaptive ability
of her own - with a high resistance to damage,
impressive regenerative abilities, and a number
of offensive capabilities, from huge claws
to a powerful dragon form.
However, considering she wasn’t even able
to defeat Ethan Winters, she probably wouldn’t
be able to defeat SCP-682, either.
However, in her dragon form, SCP-682 may finally
join the rest of us in developing a crush.
Or is that being crushed?
Anyway, moving on.
Jonathan Pecany suggested, “Just ask SCP
343 on how to destroy it, or even better,
ask if he could destroy it.”
It’s an idea so good that the Foundation
actually tried it, and it went about as well
as you can expect.
When the SCP known as God entered the containment
chamber, he couldn’t even see 682 in there,
as though the creature was somehow totally
invisible to him.
When God eventually got bored and left, they
told him that he was in there to destroy 682.
He simply replied, “He's not one of mine.
Deal with him yourself.”
Interpret that how you will.
12 Escobar Blancas Eddy Saul suggested, “They
could send him to Area 37 for The Sisters
to experiment with.”
SCP-1765, The Sisters, are a trio of terrifyingly
powerful reality warpers that have taken over
Area 37, and spend their days tormenting everyone
inside with their twisted experiments.
Using them to try to terminate 682 leads to
similar problems with using the Witch Child
or the Devourer of Worlds: If they decide
to team up rather than fighting, or the Sisters
take over 682, we’d all be effectively doomed.
Kiroyah suggested, “Would the ants from
SCP-743 tear 682 apart?”
The Foundation actually tried this, getting
682 to consume chocolate from the SCP-743
fountain, incurring the wrath of its flesh-eating
ants.
However, 682 developed an adaptation that
gave it a long, ant-eater-like tongue, that
it then used to consume the ants faster than
they could consume it.
And even worse, the chocolate seemed to enhance
its regenerative abilities even more for several
days afterwards.
Lol 2222 suggested, “Write the name in the
Death Note.”
Great idea.
We’ll put it into practice as soon as you
can tell us SCP-682’s real name.
It may come as a surprise, but its parents
didn’t actually name it the “Hard to Destroy
Reptile.”
Stephen Vierie suggested, “I thought that
maybe we should put him in a giant blender
and then when he is in small pieces put lava
in the blender so it will incinerate him then
put nuclear waste into the blender and repeat
that until there is no more left of him.”
After the cooking whisks last time, we feel
obliged to include at least one attempt to
kill SCP-682 with oversized kitchen equipment
in every video about him.
However, this attempt would probably go about
as well as the last one, we’re afraid.
Extreme physical trauma by conventional means
- like burning and dismemberment - has never
been successful in the past.
And the Foundation is extremely hesitant to
use anything radioactive on the beast, in
case it adapts and adds deadly radiation to
its own arsenal.
MrMaster IQ suggested, “Just take away his
plot armor.”
You can pry SCP-682’s plot armor from its
cold, dead claws, and as we’ve already learned,
making those claws cold and dead seems next
to impossible.
Moving on.
JC3 suggested, “HMMM IF ANYBODY CAN'T BEAT
THE UNDYING LIZARD WHY NOT OMNI MAN I MEAN
HE DID KILLED ALL THE GUARDIANS OF THE GLOBE
OF COURSE HE CAN KILL SCP-682.”
Omni-Man from the comic and TV series Invincible
is undeniably a formidable opponent, given
he’s able to destroy superhero teams, cities,
and even planets.
However, one of the few enemies to give Omni-Man
a genuine run for his money
is a genetically-enhanced
Kaiju known as Hail Mary.
Given that, first, 682 has taken on beings
stronger than Omni-Man - like the Gate Guardian
- and lived, and second, that Omni-Man has
struggled with monsters before - chances are,
he probably couldn’t permanently kill this
one, either.
Heycani Havea suggested, “Kill SCP-053,
then 682 will be sad and die.”
Wow, now that’s cold-blooded.
However, even if this did work, it’s important
for you to remember that it’s impossible
to actually kill SCP-053, also known as The
Child or the Little Girl.
Part of her anomalous abilities is that anyone
who attempts to kill her
will themselves immediately
die during the process - normally due to a
heart attack.
So this method would result in a pile of dead
Foundation personnel, and no progress.
Jerry Zhang said, “Mush peanut butter on
it.”
This would definitely work if SCP-682 has
some kind of severe peanut allergy.
After all, anaphylactic shock is no laughing
matter.
However, in the far more likely event that
this will have no effect on SCP-682, you will
likely just die with your hands covered in
peanut butter.
Andrew Mills suggested, “My idea?
Have several Xenomorphs, Predators, and Daleks
(yes that’s a Doctor Who reference) take
682 on.”
Once again, in all likelihood, this would
have no effect.
682 has survived blades and lasers - the primary
weapons of the Predators and Daleks - and
spends the majority of its life immersed in
powerful acid, so the xenomorph would hold
no surprises for it.
Sadly, this three-way teamup would be no match
for 682.
And even if they did defeat him, whoever wins,
we… well you know how it goes.
Matteo Huang suggested, “Maybe just destroy
reality.”
This.
This might be the thing that finally kills
SCP-682, but considering it’s already survived
being thrown into pure nothingness in Russia,
it may just result in it being one of the
only survivors of a full destruction of reality.
We, on the other hand, would all be killed.
Though in a sense, we wouldn’t have to deal
with SCP-682 anymore.
So maybe that’s a type of winning?
And finally, Blind Honor suggested, “Would
Saitama be a good way to eliminate it?
He is One Punch Man, after all.”
Of anyone we’ve covered in this series,
Saitama from One Punch Man would probably
be the most likely to kill SCP-682, especially
if he was taking the battle seriously.
After all, he has killed planet-destroying
monsters before with barely any effort.
The only real question is whether he could
even be bothered to come down to a Foundation
containment site and fight it.
Saitama hasn’t been known to be a very motivated
guy.
But of course, like with anything, there’s
the risk that 682 would survive and gain his
powers.
Which would be bad.
Awesome.
But bad.
Do you have new ideas for how SCP-682 could
be killed?
Do you thinkin you have the key to finally
bringing this beast to a well-deserved end?
Let us know down in the comments, and keep
an eye on our community posts for more SCP
questions like this one so you can be featured
in the next video!
Now go check out “Termination Attempts SCP-682”
and “How to Kill SCP-682 - Theories and
Ideas” for more futile attempts to murder
the Foundation’s orneriest reptile!